after much discussion and dissent
Spain's Animal Welfare Law gets the
green light
the law is the first of its kind in
Spain to guarantee the rights of animals
under the new legislation Pet Shops will
become a thing of the past and dog
owners will have to undergo training
stock shelter in southern Spain staff
look after Greyhounds that have been
abandoned often they're badly injured
for the people who work here it is a
labor of love but the new law they say
Falls far short of guaranteeing full
protections for all animals
recently we were hit by a big setback
suddenly there was an amendment where
hunting animals among other animals such
as work animals would not be covered by
this law is a huge step backwards
because this law has really been made
for these types of animals the ones that
are not controlled at the health level
the Bill's already exposed divisions
between the countryside and the city
Spain's ruling socialists traditionally
have had strong support in rural
districts but when they drafted the bill
last year it caused an outcry angering
many in those areas fearful of pushing
voters towards right-wing parties they
submitted a last-minute amendment in
December that excluded hunting dogs and
other animals involved in traditional
hunting activities but people involved
in those Pursuits say hunting in Spain
generates more than five billion dollars
a year in economic activity and that the
law would still effectively legislate it
out of existence
there's a series of points that go
against our sport for example the
obligation to sterilize our neuter
animals my dogs have been bred for 30
years raise it their grandmothers in
great grandmother's house their dogs
with an exceptional genology no what are
we supposed to do new to them
[Applause]
[Music]
thousands marched in Madrid calling for
the law to be toughened up
I believe animals should not be
exploited animals have to be free and
happy and Greyhounds and all hunting
animals have to be sleeping on a sofa
the law would increase fines for animal
abuse to more than two hundred thousand
dollars and impose a possible two-year
jail sentence for the most serious cases
and for those on opposing sides of the
debate it's further entrenched The
Divide between the two Sonic Gallego Al
Jazeera